i think this movie ends so beautifully
poised
for what could be a phenomenal sequel
are there discussions about getting the
group back together
and doing another in the heights hi
i i already started the petition yeah
yes
there is nothing that we would want more
the cast of in the heights has a suenito
they share
a sequel we all had a suenito
and when it came to dreams we had to
keep scraping by
even if it takes lynn another 20 years
to write the sequel we'll
come back we'll come back
you know like i think that there was
nothing that we would love more but we
know
writing a musical is not an easy thing
to do
so it really all depends on lin and
kiara
yeah yeah if one day you wake up and
wake up and they're like i dreamed up
the sequel
and lynn is like inspired and writes the
songs i mean
we're we're there listen it's lemon well
miranda i do not doubt that he
can do that we'll be here when that
moment happens e.t was also on hand at
the los
angeles latino international film
festival's special screening of in the
heights
where the stars gave their best ideas
for what's next
where do we see vanessa go next i think
it would be interesting to see actually
from the moment that usually decides to
stay what happens you know
what happens in those years because it
can be easy
i think it's it's important to honor the
struggle
and it's important to celebrate the
small victories and i would
i mean a sequel is a dream all of us
would
in a heartbeat come back and i think the
movie ends so brilliantly set up for the
next chapter
i agree would you be down to return as a
director
for a sequel if if lin and kiara wrote
uh the next chapter you
you bet your ass i'd be there what would
you want to see explored
wow you were digging real deep here
what's the storyline that you're dying
to tell in this next chapter
i think the next chapter is that next
generation seeing how
sunny helps guide them into uh the new
chapter of their lives and how they're
telling their stories so
that would be fun where do you see nina
in the future oh
that's a very good question um i see her
facing
you know just like everybody else many
many other obstacles and different
new ones and finding her voice and
speaking for
young people like sunny who might not
even
you know see a foreseeable future for
them in the present moment
but maybe she can just be propelled to
create that pathway for them
we have a little a little nugget from
lynn that that really
nina's dream is to become the mayor so
i don't know i'm ready i don't know so
we'll see we'll see i'll have to do a
lot of research for that because i'm
definitely not as smart as nina
but i'd love to play this is the moment
when you do better than me
because you can see a future that i can
your relationship
with leslie on screen as father daughter
it's just magical
what was it like in those moments the
two of you together on set
leslie is an accomplished singer and
and her she worked so hard on all of the
choreography
but what i was so impressed about is
that she
brought her a game in terms of opening
up her soul
and making herself available in terms of
his character and what she needed to do
as an actress and i think it shows
the movie musical is nabbing positive
reviews from fans and
critics plus early awards season buzz
but the cast insists their top priority
is representation
on screen in the original production
carl and daniella were simply work
partners um
but in this iteration kiara and john
and lynn all felt really strongly that
they should be life partners as well
if you're looking at your phone you
might miss the first time that they wake
up in bed together you know
but what's really great for me as a
person who is queer who's a member of
the queer community who's bisexual
is to see that rep in a film where
it's just layered into the community
sort of in the background and they're
this really
functional fun happy funny couple that
just happen to be gay
i think carnaval del barrio will
definitely
have an impact on people it will
definitely make
everyone's heart swell with pride and
want to claim and like
raise their flags up and in in the
moment the energy just felt
like rich and and like we were making
history so hopefully
uh people when they see that number they
can feel that energy i realized a couple
years ago that i was in a position of
power to to change the stories that i
was choosing to tell and
uh again i'm just one little movie and
one little moment but i know that
there's a lot more coming and uh and we
just have to meet the moment that's our
responsibility
if you talk to me 10 years ago we
would've been talking about another kind
of movie
that had a latino theme that we wanted
to break through and i think that time
is right and
the universe is aligned for something of
quality that
the audiences will be able to be engaged
with it's just
beautiful to be a part of something that
feels bigger than you
and that feels so autobiographical even
though you've had nothing to do with
like the creation
and the brilliance that it that it took
to make it and i feel so blessed
for my family that has been you know
rooting rooting me on for their stories
to be cherished through something that i
don't
[Music]